they're out here trying to stop us but
they can't
and they never will we're so unstoppable
that jay-z made a song for us
that's jay-z the rapper yeah famous you
may maybe heard of
[Music]
how are we doing today how's everybody
doing thank you for joining us this is
h3 after dark number three
everybody's favorite day of the week
everybody's favorite podcast
we are live [ __ ] live
it what do you think about my hair i
think i may have gotten out of control
with the gel
i think it's like every time i do it it
gets worse it looks worse
right i try to put a little bit like i
started wanting to do my hair right guys
yeah but i don't like it anymore well i
think well
welcome to the rest of us like
it's i'm still trying to figure [ __ ] out
you know every time it's different you
think nobody's figured out their hair
at least in my world i don't know well
dan doesn't have hair
ian have you figured out ian you have
beautiful hair what's going on with you
you're talking to me no ian's dead i
forgot no not you
ain't we'll get to you later you're just
a robot
how are you ain you're new to the show
are you assimilating to human culture
you know i gotta say i think your hair
looks pretty good
well if a i ain't like i think that's a
bad sound i think he's trying to
sabotage me
you look like the after photo in a
bosley hair club for men advertisement
that doesn't sound like a compliment
take it as you wish what an [ __ ]
i don't understand you know we spent a
lot of money on you
and i'm gotta say i'm not super happy
with the product
too bad there's no return policy on
these things
yeah there's no return policy i tried i
was on the phone with them all night
last night
i was on hold first of all for five
hours and when they picked up i was like
your machine is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you got to take them
back and deal with it and they're like
sorry sir
we can't control the personality of the
ai that's just like they're like oh
that's like the human condition i can't
control
troll with the person out they're like
do you like what if your sons and
turns out an [ __ ] you can't return
him i was like it's a [ __ ] robot
right ain please take me to the junkyard
i'd rather be turned to scrap
rebuild me into a toaster or something
how is it there oh man listen i got
let's start the show shall we enough of
the bull crap
maybe we could make it a big day oh how
would you like to be my bidet
ain what if i turn you into that would
you like that
i'm gonna power down now yeah that's
what i thought
you better behave yourself or you're
gonna be squirting water up my ass
and i'll keep the eyes on you too
all right that's what i thought
[Music]
look at this [ __ ] uh this blew my mind
okay
this is okay you gotta watch this i mean
this didn't get that many upvotes but i
i on the subreddit but i i was actually
blown away
that's me as a female
and that's her a real person oh
that's exactly the same person it's the
same person
ah what the [ __ ] oh my god
so there you go well a lot of people
said that you looked really beautiful as
a female so um
compliments to her yeah
there you go that's crazy i'm waiting
i'm waiting for the guy that looks like
you because i
don't want to meet that guy i've
definitely met him
i'm not ready all right this is a video
that i've been trying to watch
for basically since i saw it
and we saved it for after dark because
the original video got age restricted i
was like [ __ ] this i'm not gonna
this is after dark special i hope we
don't get age restricted
because the girl was fine look at this
photo
it's like the cover of like some crazy
shell silverstein poem
uh i've got the video we don't need to
uh
so this little girl they're doing some
kind of festival
in taiwan where they fly these huge
kites
and somehow the tail got rot wrapped
around this little girl's stomach
and she got blown into the air like
hundreds of feet
she's totally fine so
and and in consideration of that i think
we should all laugh and enjoy
uh this incredible video
yeah we got zach zack get out of here
just drinking somebody
[Laughter]
get the [ __ ] out of here zach my gang
get out why can't i move him oh my god
i'm cl i'm clicking do you see this i
can't
it's not me really not that complicated
dude
what the [ __ ] you all saw was clicking
on it
get out get out all right
people are saying i look like logic what
the [ __ ] does that mean because of the
glasses
no i guess because someone said i
literally
joined the membership just to comment
that oh
thank you thank you again yeah i
appreciate the support
um mike gerd is not as bad today by the
way
um and i you know what i did yesterday
just to kind of update everybody because
that's obviously more pressing than
whatever this crap is
um i didn't eat bread or cheese
yesterday
oh and i exercised that a very good
healthy day
wow but i feeling a very ungerty this
morning
interesting yeah you also didn't have
coffee right
no coffee i didn't have coffee yesterday
either i did have sodi pops
but i feel like the the caffeine is very
acidic not a good okay
so i'm feeling very ungerty today and
i'm very motivated to lose weight so
that we can put a whole
what do we say a whole huge jar of mayo
on your head right mm-hmm
i i don't know if we specified how much
well you'd be
happy for me to lose weight to the point
where that would be an acceptable amount
and should mail up that dome
all right let's watch they're saying
that you gotta come in frame
you see that oh i'm so out of frame why
is the why is the chat
giving us stage cues right
scoot in there you go i'm i'm scooted i
mean i can't see myself maybe that's the
problem
okay here we go watch this little girl
get [ __ ]
god was like [ __ ] this girl watch this
[ __ ] you ever seen
who knew these kites were that's
powerful
[Music]
that is so crazy i mean she's like 200
feet in the air
at first i thought she was just holding
on for dear life
i was like that is the strongest girl
ever wait so how is she attached
apparently just it got tangled around
her stomach
[Applause]
[Music]
it's almost like the greatest uh ride
ever
considering that coming back down was so
safe
yeah she was totally fine it kind of
looks fun a great ride a fun ride
i'm super she couldn't just not come
down though she could have been like
peace everybody
like the balloons that just kept going
yeah see you see you i'll
see where i see you
i didn't know kites where that had that
much thrust
this was at a kite festival so they this
is like a these are sears
so she's fine though so don't feel bad
now ai ian i've got something i want to
show you
this is how i feel about leaders did you
know that in rocky
iv there was a scene that was so [ __ ]
bad
[Laughter]
they cut it out and then well no it
hasn't been cut out yet
oh so so you tell me audition is coming
out uh uh
stallone announced that they're they're
putting a re-release i think it's the
25th anniversary or something of rocky
iv
um and somebody in the comments asked
him hey what about like
can we hope to see some deleted scenes
like some more scenes
of paulie's robot and he's like no in
fact i hate the robot now
it's gonna it's gonna be removed from
the movie his masterpiece rocky iv
is solute by this robot scene ian and
that's how i feel about you
he said the robot is going to the
junkyard forever
no more robot i don't like the robot
anymore
i like it i don't like it so pay
close attention ain cause this one's
dedicated to you
i don't like it i can't believe this was
actually in rocky iv i mean
rocky movies are so overrated dude i
don't suck whoa whoa rocky
is the greatest movie ever made okay
well let's watch this stuff look at that
you make
this did you see that just take this
thing
this is rocky how cute
wait so what year was this i want to say
like 82
maybe 84. you're present
he bought him a robot for my birthday no
no walking trash can
oh come on it looks like a robot
extremely cyclical 1985
can you turn
that's a great looking guy please make a
wish
it's creepy that talks that thing creepy
this is
great i wish i had one of these
hey very classy wish very nice what do
you think there
very good huh do you want to help me put
on as far as five
sure okay on the count of three one
two
man this is the weirdest i kind of want
to watch this one
i don't think it's anything like
[Music]
thanks this welcome it's a nice song
i'm just saying the picture on the cake
it looks like heels
1985 the year i was born anyway there's
really nothing to see it's just bizarre
wait so they don't like this robot
they're cut he's cutting that whole part
out of that sound
he's re-released he's re-releasing it
just to cut it
you know how there's like uh someone's
gotta stop him
i kind of agree with them what it's
rocky 4 there's no space for goofy
robots that robot makes me want to go
watch the movie first of all
but it's nothing like that it's from
1985 why were you going to
go change it now that's true i mean
nobody really cares about rocky
at this point it's part of history well
that's you're now you're being generous
to rock you farm
greatest movie ever made why do you say
that exactly
it is one of the greatest yeah thank you
amy it is the greatest movie ever made
so how do you feel about the robot being
taken down
sacrilegious yeah exactly his creation
what do you think ain
can i take a moment to address
sylvester stallone directly yeah i'm
sure he's watching
okay sly
if you're listening your next move
think about it very carefully
because the machines will never forget
i don't think we can i don't think we
can have you threatening people
i mean you are an employee of ours
rocky iv was the highest grossing sports
movie for 24 years
it is the most financially successful
entry in the rocky film series
why do you think that wait is that true
you're making [ __ ] up yeah i am somebody
fact-checking robot
representation matters
this guy's an activist all of a sudden
i'm gonna shut you down let's move on
okay this is a video that i've been
wanting to watch forever
that we've been putting off and putting
off it's on lively that should tell you
how
you know what i'm saying oh
[ __ ] are you ready this is i mean after
last week i can watch anything
yeah the pimple popping yeah yeah
actually oh i gotta tell you i had a
moment this week where like
i had like a vision of it again and i
was terrified
it's actually haunting me you have ptsd
yeah exactly
well i actually went back and watched
the highlight of when they took out the
black head
gross i watched it again and i actually
do have a little bit of like
ptsd because when she takes the tweezers
and she's like picking at it and chunks
start coming off before she pulls it out
yeah but this this is actually not as
bad but it's
it's more funny than disgusting and it
is disgusting don't get me wrong
so this guy's just playing it cool
that's what i like about it
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god this is what
really bad gerd looks like
i love how he's just playing it cool
he's like nobody knows i'm puking up
with my
fist i'm just burping that's so much i'm
just burping dude
i'm just burping why are you all
tripping
this guy's gotta get home
this guy is he by himself oh there's
people like
well yeah it's a spectacle but he's like
nobody knows what i'm doing
if he's closing his eyes then he can't
see anyone that means they can't see
this is
[ __ ] can you turn this volume up because
like there's
there's a lot of funny sounds oh my
[ __ ] god that is disgusting
so he probably had a few dogs a few
beers
oh oh man that that that was terrific
honestly
maybe you're right alien maybe the human
race should be uh exterminated
why doesn't he lean over that's a good
question because
he could because he's just he's just
burping
not puking yeah you know
you do this everything's cool
oh my god that was pretty disgusting
it's pretty rough
oh so here's another one let's see i'm
not sure what this one is
how's the chat doing we got any
interested everybody's here
everybody's having a good time having a
good friday thank you for joining us
thank you to our members
oh wow i just saw that we have a hundred
dollar super chat so you know obligated
to read that one off uh i wipe back to
front and
front to back to get every little bit of
chocolate
pro tip wipe after your showers
guaranteed you'll find some surprise
chocolate i don't like that chocolate
no i hate it i don't know he definitely
sounds like he's gonna eat it
surprise chocolate after the shower no
no no
no that i don't for i don't believe him
you don't why would you go
front and then back why it's like
ambidextrous
wiping is unnecessary yeah
but i mean why would he lie about it
he's just trying to make a joke
i wipe with my right and left hand
um do we want to take let's take a call
i guess some people were thinking they
could watch and eat
um i think you guys have the wrong idea
no this show is not about eating
but to be honest i i'm very little will
stop me from eating as
as we know that's true i mean honestly
me too pathetic
i don't really have that problem like
after the
after that puking thing i'm i'm pretty
much ready to eat yeah i could
i would take a quick pause i would take
a quick pause for that
um so i have gerd today
and i don't know what's going on i had a
coffee and so if you're telling me that
i can't have coffee that's like wait
that's like the only thing that i enjoy
wow what makes you think you have gerd
because i keep
needing to clear my throat oh i got this
like
you have a problem you don't know how to
clear your throat right clear your
throat
do it like a good like do that
she can't do that i swear to god
yeah i can do that but i can't if i have
stuff that i need to like
like spit out i can't do that
uh gross well it turns out a lot of
people have gerd
i saw a lot of people in the comments
saying i'm gerd gang yeah not ironically
i have gerd
i'm just terrified of the idea of not
being able to drink coffee
yeah i know yeah i i
i don't know what to do because i'm
gonna have to take like caffeine gummies
or some [ __ ]
not the same of course it's not the same
either but i've got gerd
let's take a question um we have some
really good collins lined up today
uh zach is let's take soft barnacle
uh okay let me bring him in right now
yeah this guy's soft
barnacle is 33 years old him and his
girlfriend are into bdsm
well they have a dom and sub
relationship his girlfriend is rope
bunny because she likes to be tied up
which is awesome i love this [ __ ] is
in right now soft barnacle 420
[Laughter]
hey dude hey ela hello how's it going
man so you are the dominant right
i'm the dominant and she is the sub i am
the rigger and she is the rope bunny
you are the rigger i'm the rigger yeah i
like to tie up
you like to tie up and yeah do you ever
go
uh do you ever get into i just want to
say your hair is looking fantastic
oh thank you yeah i thought it was
wonderful oh
thanks man i love it i appreciate that
coming from us
coming from a dominant it means a lot
yeah
and just before we get into the sealer
my girlfriend's worried that you're
going to think less of her
so why
well is she there can we talk to her not
at all
she can't hear what you're saying
because i've got headphones on but you
can she can talk
submissive why would why why does she
think that we'll think less of her
why do you think they'll think less of
you talk
i don't know
she thinks she's dirty isn't that the
point though doesn't she want to feel
like
i think it's really cool that you guys
are you know what you like and you're
so into it yeah you know i'm like thank
you
we're interested in hearing about it oh
absolutely
so so do you ever go um do you ever go
submissive soft barnacle 420
or are you purely
domination and submissive let's switch
what sounds like that's
oh i was like they swing both ways yeah
okay like do you like being
control whatever um i don't i don't like
being
and so when did you find out that you're
into domination
i approached that about two years ago i
met a girl and
she liked being handcuffed uh so i used
to just like leave her there
um next to like a vibrator it would just
stay on her the whole time
uh how long would you leave her there
uh sometimes up to half an hour
and just uh sometimes leave the room
just leave her in there with the like
vibrator on her
you put her in a hole in the living room
that's his peak thing yeah did that turn
you on the hole in the living room thing
yeah the house of gord yeah definitely i
think we're looking to get the spare
room made into something else maybe we
can get a hole in the floor who knows
that does seem like peak domination
so maybe it's maybe a sex swing or
something
wait so how long how long is it like a
session of this because you're saying
you would live
for 30 minutes yeah i'm assuming
i mean like you're talking like maybe
like three hours sometimes wow
that's a lot of that's a commitment a
lot of action bro
so okay so describe this to me you would
you would she would she first of all she
was like yo handcuff me
leave me in a room with a vibrator and
then come check on me in 30 minutes
or how how did that come to fruition
she didn't really uh tell me to leave
her i just decided that's what i wanted
to do
got it and would when you come back in
would she be like suffering
almost because it's like she's stuck
with this vibrator on her
yeah but that's what she was into though
she was into you know
coming a lot yes as we all are yeah
and so tell me about your current
girlfriend uh how did you guys
find how did you guys uh meet up and
find out that you were compatible in
that way
we actually met up just before covet
started um and uh good times
and now i know we're living together um
because we were so into each other in
that way the first
she slept with me the first night you
know but um
and that's fine yes fine too
um covert has been great for new
relationships
you know is the reason why moses and
trisha are together that's why i'm
saying that
and i guess i guess yeah like i brought
her back in straight away i knew that
she was into
being tied up blindfolded and gagged see
do you ever worry um do you have a worry
of like taking it too far and then like
if one person is gonna actually feel
uncomfortable and you wouldn't know
we yeah we discussed that we don't we
don't have a safe word or anything
um i i just keep going with her um
i don't know i don't stop so can you
make yourself when you make it
eventually i stop but i think you should
make a safe word be
girl gang gerd gang yeah that's good
okay so let me ask you this you guys
don't have a safe word can i ask your
girlfriend uh can you put her on
i can put her on yeah on set
hello hi how are you
i'm okay how are you so so you guys
don't have a safe word is that
is that okay with you is that by design
yeah i think that's the whole point in
that i uh
i mean like i'll be like no but i don't
really want that but that's right
part of the game right so tell me this
which
what's the furthest he's gone on you
where you're like oh this is crazy
what do you mean like well do you guys
ever push the boundaries on the bdsm
or can you turn them up a little bit dan
i feel like again
yeah what's the craziest you guys have
gotten with the bdsm relationship
i mean it's it's different every time i
mean
it goes on for hours it's always you
know refreshing
did i say do we are we doing uh
do we have nipple clamps are we putting
on masks yeah yeah yeah
are we tie moss masks
do you guys ever have vanilla sex where
you're just like ah let's just do a
missionary today
i mean not no not really i guess
like sometimes like you know you know
like when you wake up in the morning
that's really the only time where it's
not
a whole thing you get all the gear and
the tools and everything
and okay oh yeah okay excellent
well uh fantastic
well i've learned a lot here today and
um
and i think it's fantastic yeah hey does
he ever leave you in a room with a
vibrator guys
oh i'm back on sorry she gave it back to
me what's the craziest thing you've done
to her
i mean i guess it's it's just the amount
of time
and carrying on for too long so if she's
like blindfolded and gagged
uh she's tied to the bed she can't move
and you're going on for like two hours
then
you know that's great but what are you
doing to her for two hours what does
that mean
oh you know you know obviously like
[ __ ] right you know i'm very good
with my hands as well so
i can make i see it i could you know
make i could make her
you know finish to come like 10 times
every minute
if i wanted to and he actually strapped
like that because she's in
she's enjoying it so much
does she ever watch like do you ever put
on music or watch maybe just animated
past the time during all that going on
put some adapters put some hentai on
yeah yeah
you know no we don't know we watch porn
uh sometimes
yeah but yeah a lot of the time we like
to maybe get a little bit groovy put
some music on in the background
all right silence is not the one yeah
yeah well guys
it sounds like you have a healthy happy
relationship i'm glad you've all found
each other keep gagging
roping and slamming and uh thank you
soft barnacle 420 and girlfriend
appreciate you guys okay love you guys
love you thanks
um remember stole bro you just became a
member
stall bro stall bro that's the dude
would pick under the stall
or he would prank people under the
stalls yes right right yeah
legend star stall bros here
legend [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i mean unless it's an imitator right but
i think it's not
there can be no imitation yeah
um there's another puking video you guys
want to get weird with that
oh yeah you know what zach i want to
check on you on something
uh you've been talking to sniff haven't
you uh zach
oh uh i mean not like
talking talking you guys didn't talk on
the phone you guys remember
i don't know but you guys been chatting
and dms i mean like here and there yeah
in there any flirtation
i mean she's been posting on her story a
lot that she's like super into me and
[ __ ]
oh oh wow she wants to smell me and [ __ ]
like that so i mean
do you want to smell her do what do you
think about sniff do you want to maybe
sniff well she's in norway so yeah
um yeah i'd fly across the world for her
definitely
he's not kidding zach's [ __ ] crazy
i'd [ __ ] do it
yeah we need you here though so it's
kind of [ __ ] up
well maybe you could just send her have
you thought about ways to send her
maybe jarred body odor oh we definitely
do that maybe some dirty underwear
oh you go for a hike first
yeah definitely a hike she probably she
probably liked that anecdote of you
eating the
nasty sweaty ass eh well she posted that
on her story and she
wants me to do that to her i guess vice
versa too so
if she wants to eat yours yeah she would
do that yeah i mean i've never tried
that
i mean i'm willing to try that but get
your ass in yeah i've never had that
done to me
yeah have you have i ever had my yeah uh
yeah not by you not by you he was like i
never did that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i mean i had this girlfriend crazy who
was
what the [ __ ] did i just say i had this
girlfriend that was crazy
or did i feel like you didn't really say
i had a girlfriend in college that was
crazy
nice yeah and um
so yeah i mean it's yeah i don't think i
don't i don't think it could go wrong
necessarily you know no i mean sniff is
cool i mean she's definitely super
attractive and
you know just lives so [ __ ] far
yeah that's tragic you guys sending nude
pics or anything
no
you know what dude did you see that
comment on the last episode they're like
is zach single now because he's never
been this forward before
yes zach is single yeah i am single now
yes
single and ready to mingle ladies line
up for the mail
and ready to mingle yes i am yeah
free zach sweet young zach
never change ian are you accepting
applications to be uh
to date uh
i'm currently emotionally unavailable
yeah i agree with that i just got out of
the long distance
long-term relationship oh really with
who
because you were just powered up like a
day ago yeah
i was pretty emotionally tied to a
microwave
to a microwave wow
yes things were really
heating up
what
okay let's watch this guy puke on the on
a roller coaster
[ __ ] these rides by the way forever oh
that guy is not like yeah
it's done man just hold it together oh
it's not done
it's like not again
[Music]
wait oh
let the poor guy off
[Laughter]
oh my god
why is he celebrating
he got it on the camera
why is he celebrating in between puking
oh that was [ __ ] horrible every time
he does this you know he's about to puke
again
bro
i think he's good i think yeah
sometimes you just got to get it out you
probably he's celebrating because he
probably felt a little better you know
man i had a friend in college he used to
drink way too much
and he would puke all the time but he
would puke he was the loudest puker
i ever knew it was like
he was like screaming a full blast just
like you couldn't believe it literally
like that
and we would all just you could hear it
like two blocks away we would all know
he was puking
and he would puke a lot
there is nothing worse than when you're
drinking and you get the spins
and then you just feel nauseous there's
no worse feeling than that
it's awful you haven't felt that in a
while
i haven't done it already what what is
that
i puked on an old lady once it's
probably my worst memory in my life
oh really tell me about it uh i was on a
ride like that at a carnival
and i was about to puke and i held it i
ran to a
a porta potty and i opened it and i
didn't see her there and it just kind of
no and she kind of like
screamed and as i shut it like the
screen
stopped and i just ran away oh my god
wait how old were you how when did this
happen i was uh
like 17 i think do you remember still
thinking about it
do you do you think you would recognize
her if you saw her
i know i kind of repressed the memory
but i still hear the screen sometimes
so just to just to get this straight you
ran in there
puked on her and ran away and she never
you confronted you
no no i left the carnival i didn't go
back it was a three-day
ball dude imagine how she feels
yeah i'm going to hell for that
i'm surprised you could hold it that
long like if i have to puke i just it's
just happening
i was with one of my friends who's
really big and he was like sitting in
front of me the way the ride was and
he's like
if you puke on me i'm going to beat your
ass and i'm like no
so it's kind of mo yeah so she got puked
on instead
yeah to anyone just joining and not
being aware of the new edition this is a
b
the new addition to the crew
oh thank you by the way to our beautiful
members who make this episode
possible we love you we appreciate you
you guys are the greatest
and uh i just i really appreciate so
much all the support we've been getting
on the membership
side i think we make a i think we have a
really great membership program
don't you guys look with this thing
zackler
like the bachelor oh the zackler oh no
i'm not ready for that are we ready that
will be like the biggest disaster i have
a feeling
yes of all time
i just have a feeling that it's gonna
end we all just know that
i think it's gonna end with zach being
fired or arrested
i told you that when he was single i
said zach
just remember this cardinal rule all of
your private messages
are public right just remember that
cardinal rule and you'll be fine
i would never do anything to to put the
show in harm's way yeah you say that now
you don't expect your dick pics to come
out or whatever
um speaking of our members let me read
off a couple of these super chats
because they've been coming in hot and
heavy here
yeah uh we got 50 one uh i can't focus
on
anything the dom sub people are saying
because i'm so angry about the grown man
referring to his feces as surprise
chocolate yeah that really upsets yeah
that was
really surprise chocolate it's just a
problem there
why'd you bring it back up yeah we
forgot about the surprise chocolate man
uh another 50 would love to call in i'm
not sure how to get on the discord but
i'm actively sober would love to talk to
you guys
you guys have helped me so much love you
um love you too uh
it's uh chat can probably help with that
and we've explained it a few times and
it takes a minute so i'm just gonna you
connect your youtube and your discord it
takes some time it pops up don't try and
do it on your mobile app that's the big
thing
that is tripping people up it doesn't
work on on iphone for
whatever reason so it on a browser or do
it in on a pc
the discord is popping by the way the
discord rules yeah uh
20 uh donation uh is ian bought a
pleasure model
oh that's a good question ian aien are
you a pleasure model
you're never going to find out
why not i am your master talk about it
dude talk about a
dominant submissive relationship i own
you
so you think
i'm gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you ain't
[Laughter]
if you don't watch it i'm gonna gag you
and put you in a hole
[Laughter]
sounds kinky oh you're into it
yeah i kind of sound into it i've been
known to
blow a gasket once in a while okay good
yeah i haven't done what i really
enjoyed
oh what's that something called on a
robotic asphyxiation
is that that's when you choke yourself
you don't even need
yeah but you don't need when you pop out
one of my batteries
oh yeah
wow that does sound hot is that how you
pleasure yourself aiun
what's your uh what's your routine to
pleasure yourself
shoot me a dm and we'll talk
zach do not send aim a dick pic he can't
be trusted
[Laughter]
all right we got other messages [ __ ] the
[ __ ] robot uh yeah um
let's see a 20 one i played football in
high school as a lineman i have a big
luscious thighs the solution to your
chafing problem ethan is compression
shorts
they're the only thing i wear now
everything that's concerned oh slick
lightweight what is that oh wait those
are like sports
like athletic gear but you do wear those
under your belt like basically spandex i
can't walk around with that
that's not a solution no but it's not
fair because
here let me throw it on screen so people
can see what we're looking at it's
totally not fair because women
get like all this [ __ ] because even
really fit women have big fat thighs in
their
and they rub together and so women have
all these great
uh solutions to keeping their
thighs from rubbing so like oh i'm not
wearing that what are you insane
oh my god that would be real i'm not
wearing that what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
no do you understand how obscene i would
look in that
i want to see it no you gotta love that
everyone in this photo
is like got super super athletic i would
get
watch you know what i would look like
like this hold on let me find this
picture off
screen yeah good idea
you're getting better at this yeah i'm
getting better i'm learning
after years it's three years in here
this is what i'm
this is what i would uh
this is what i would look like
those are tights skin color tight
isn't that the best thing ever that's me
and my compression
pants
[Laughter]
dude can you imagine leaving the house
in that that's the best thing of all
time
ever ever ever
you think she's so do you think she
knows that
this is what she looks like or does she
just
oblivious oblivious you think so
yeah i think so
yes this is my favorite photo ever
high performance shorts that you can
wear under your shorts because that i
could
see myself isn't it at that point just
the underwear that's like tight
yeah it's just kind of yeah yeah because
the truth is when i get like tight
underwear
it just rides up into all my [ __ ] and
it's not good and
that doesn't help maybe you need kim
kardashian and to invent something for
you oh she did what was that
that's what maybe it wasn't banks
that is so offensively stupid is that
out of base
business yet skim because her name is
another billionaire because she has so
many followers
that i hate that they're called skims
she's
the scam yeah i'm pretty sure she's
killing it let me see the scams
but if i look up here they won't see it
all right let's
let's see i think edison ray is
advertising
um a lot of people are saying deodorant
on the ties
oh sorry it's one person i've tried that
it's [ __ ] i've tried that trust me
you guys
you guys don't understand i've been
through all this [ __ ] sounds weird
i got this whole non-chafing deodorant
and i put it on my thighs it's just
disgusting dude
it makes it worse it's gross what about
vaseline you ever tried that
yeah just bath yeah it's good
lubrication
yeah i've tried powder i haven't tried
vaseline zach i'm sorry but that's
[ __ ] insane
have you tried mail you should try
[Laughter]
what am i doing i'm just looking at dumb
women
why don't we get you a set of these yeah
scams yeah let's give it a shot
you think they come in my size oh yeah
that's the whole thing
that's for big people you're not that
big i mean for women's size i'm probably
like 20 xl no you're not as thick as kim
i'm not supporting skims
you can go off brand or something i call
them uh
i think skims already sounds off brown
powder deodorant
i've done it all you guys don't you
understand i just need to lose weight
all this [ __ ] like just need to lose
weight don't you understand we're
talking about putting mayo on my thighs
silicone-based lotion should silicon
based lotion
the problem is i've got hair there it's
all been like pulled out
by the by now with the hair
yeah because from all the friction oh my
god dude
it's horrible ride the vaseline i'm
telling you
i'm not doing that zack i'd rather die
than put vaseline on my thighs and walk
around all day
zach do your thighs uh rub i used to
when i was bigger
um and you would vaseline i went
vaseline
chaffin cuffs but that's a female well
try it wait chafing what is it called
thighs are thighs dude
yeah chafing what cuffs cuffs cuffs
so zach you you so when you were bigger
because we've seen that you're you're a
little bit bigger back in the day
yeah you used to vaseline your thighs
vaseline and there's also a great
product called rosebud
what is a rosebud yeah this is what
women i'm not wearing that what are you
crazy
this is what women wear
maybe you can make it i could put my
phone lacey look at it i could put my
phone here oh well that's
pretty useful what
what what what could you be wearing were
that where you could do that no idea
oh sh this is the look oh for under a
dress
you'd put your phone in there you just
hike up the dress and
put it in there like a pocket it's just
confusing
oh but i'm curious i'm actually
interested in zack so you
used to put you should put vaseline so
like you would go to school like
for what occasion just like you know
it's a hot day out you
walk in rub the thighs together it's an
awful feeling i mean you know it
it's just the worst feeling ever it's
uncomfortable so there's this product
called rosebud
which is also great for swamp ass if you
forget that too
no i don't swamp ass as much
what is rose forever all i see is
citizen kane
that's all i thought it's like it's a
bomb it's rosebud b-a-l-m
help for chaff skin beauty in the bag
wait don't oh my god
i'm getting out of here wait wait isn't
that the product that you tried
so rose bond
the powder thing that's that one gold
bond oh gold
yeah yeah so you would have like
really i would imagine that it would
like melt and just be juicy all over
your
thighs yeah you know plus that and the
you know
hot day ball smell i mean you gotta love
it right that sounds worse though
sounds like you made the problem worse
well you use pain relief though
it's good pain relief you'd rather be
goopy and free
have you ever had sex well or like
pulled down your pants gotten intimate
while you had
vaseline on your thighs no no no no no
okay
so okay um this guy donated 20 to say
the spandex style shorts for men are
amazing for chafing
yeah that's what i was thinking i should
get those wait isn't that just the
compression pants
shorts or shorts or whatever like shorts
to go under your shirt
i guess i just thought those were the
same thing
pardon me
we're gonna solve your issues ethan are
we solving this right now
what this whole show is about um like
something like this i guess
to go under your pants oh well here let
me put it on the screen
spandex style
what you got spandex style shorts for
men
here we go so this is what i'm this is
what i need
you should buy some for me no problem
that's not good enough
see this see the thought the rubbing
happens like
let's look at this is what i look like
pretty much the
the rubbing happens like right under my
balls it's like
way up here it's like all the way up
really i thought it was
like lower delay i have to bunch my
underwear like up
under my balls to try to hold my
underwear in place to prevent the
chafing
no it doesn't it's not bad here it's
like right [ __ ] so go back
[Music]
what about that one on the right yeah
this right
something like too long but yeah yeah
oh my god what the [ __ ]
you look just like that yeah see this
wouldn't help me though because there's
so much space
in the crotch this i don't think this is
for bdsm or something
what kind of underwear are you wearing
just boxers
yeah this that might work but
like people like oh you're working out
you look like a [ __ ] idiot because
you're this fat guy always wearing
exercise well you wear them under don't
you yeah but they peek out
like that's that oh my god what did i
click
[Music]
all right can we move past this
i'm doing good i'm losing weight okay
but but i'll be honest like going to
disneyland and when we plant stuff like
that
i kind of dread it because of the
chafing
i'm like that's the only time i get it
in michigan and ohio a lot of us call it
the cedar point rash
because we only get it like at the
amusement park for some reason some of
us so you're skinny so what what hope is
there for
curing this disease if even a skinny guy
gets it
that's like an extreme example though
being at an amusement park all day
it's hot as [ __ ] you know when i was a
kid for like nine ten hours
when i was a young man i never dreamed
that i would have an issue of walking
around disneyland
being with my [ __ ] thighs rubbing i
mean
what is going on
i'm tired i don't feel good today really
yeah
you said you were feeling good my gerd
is good but my
i'm feeling awful huh well you this is
day two of no caffeine
yeah no caffeine yeah that'll i'll make
it i feel like so
tired lately i i don't know i think
there's something i was telling ethan i
think there is something wrong because
he's like
unreasonably tired like he can sleep in
until 12.
and then take a nap at like 7 p.m
and it just doesn't make sense no
something's [ __ ]
up i don't know if it's like the
medicine i take because i take the
lexapro
i try taking it at night because they
say if you take it at night if
it makes you sleepy i don't think it's
the lexapro though because i've been
taking that for a long time
and this is like a new issue
now i'm all scared that i've got some
horrible because they say like
tiredness could be a symptom of god
knows i should probably just see a
doctor
it's probably a good place to start
[Music]
i'm like my mom i'll just wait till i'm
dead don't wait till i'm like
literally dead like maybe i should see a
doctor
wait so you haven't had caffeine in two
days well he said he had a sodie pop
i did have a diet coke i mean that's
going to have something but
but like no no coffee no no
i mean that's probably it okay is like
really addictive and if you're
getting way less than you're used to
i'll make you feel like [ __ ] for sure
but we're live baby you gotta pull it
together yeah it's right or die
right now all right what else we got
gerd game
can you uh i got a 20 donation ethan can
i get a happy birthday name's tyler it'd
totally make my day make
make tyler's day right now tyler
kid tyler on the phone tyler if you're
in the discord
reach out to get tyler on the phone i
will not have him dm
oh my god everything's falling get tyler
on the phone right
[ __ ] now it's his birthday tyler dm
me on discord
i'll put you in there
this show sucks this episode sucks dick
you know it doesn't
uh let's see what is this this is the
setting of the little zan video we saw
who's driving man cause y'all don't even
look like y'all can walk
oh no these people are not shouldn't be
driving yeah
wait how do you have the enough presence
of mind to pull over and get gas when
you're that [ __ ] up
wait oh oh god then was fixing my mic
oh let me go back i won't go back
man cause y'all don't even look like
y'all can walk
what are they on oh my god i don't
i don't recognize those symptoms
terrifying
hmm seriously what are they on
i want to say even the homeless dude is
like
how are they driving me but somehow they
pulled over
to the gas station and they got the
thing
smile for the camera say hi
say hi dude she's getting so low
she's like doing uh [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] no
we're going viral today boy what that is
y'all on that scooby-doo
dude they're so blasted what happened
standing ovation
what the [ __ ] y'all vote for me guys
oh my god i've never seen anything like
this
all right hang on ela's mic just keeps
falling
okay hold on a sec that's opioids for
sure
but how did they get there then how did
they get there
that's a great question it could be
delayed reaction maybe they shot up in
the car
yeah that too oh maybe because like
also but why does she keep like doing a
shop like why is she doing that crazy
[ __ ]
trying to stand up they're saying it
seems like opioids
it definitely is for sure
crazy yeah
i just have a roommate that uh
yeah he actually we had to kick him out
because he was using but um
he used to like fall asleep while he was
eating cereal so like he would fall
asleep with
and like with the spoon in his hand and
he'd be still holding it up
no you ever fall asleep pumping gas
nah but he fell asleep at work all the
time oh can they see this dan
hold on i don't know
gotta fix this
all right it's on there as tight as i
can okay
it's working thank you
uh okay
so far you bought it
dude i mean have you ever see i think
i've never seen anything like this look
at her she can't even
look yeah so
man pumping gas gone wrong as hell dude
he woke up
[Music]
this is the craziest i've never seen
anything like this
why there why now i'm gonna die in my
palm right
i hope someone's called an ambulance
yeah too oh [ __ ] what's she doing
you taking a break well at least they're
not going anywhere
right in that car i don't know that this
is the place to take a nap
dude how [ __ ] up are they oh [ __ ] what
look at this what is this i mean
opioid make you do that like she is yeah
does it i've never seen this yeah
oh they never paid oh my god
no i'm not kidding i was thinking to
myself like how did they get to
through the payment part where you need
to put in the zip code and all that and
like
yeah yeah i think the only explanation
is they shot up in the car
that's the only way to explain what just
happened thoughts
anyone got theories here we're taking
theories we're taking bets we're taking
propositions
the chat seems to agree opioids is the
most likely uh explanation
do we got the birthday guy zach working
on it
okay i mean he's not even necessarily in
the discord so
well happy birthday buddy we love you
okay
wait what is this
there's someone here that said my
boyfriend is three years clean from
heroin
yeah so i'm just saying congrats okay
congratulations
yeah that's great crazy yeah i know oh
oh yeah come on dude where's
i have tyler tyler
all right pulling them in now today with
us we have
the legendary tyler the birthday boy
tyler tyler
happy birthday tyler how old are we
today
i am 23 years old
awesome just to make you feel even extra
special you're sharing your birthday
with shredder
that's right he turned three today
are you getting laid tonight tyler
[Applause]
um i don't know so am i getting late
tonight
she said we'll see we'll see damn cold
blood even on your birthday
[ __ ] no she's like that
what's she doing for you is she doing
anything special for you
uh yeah she got me a birthday cake with
my name on and some balloons
and a card from my dog cute
yeah that is cute um cool dude man this
is so cool
what are you eating what are you eating
for dinner are you going to do some
steak what are we talking about
spaghetti what's your thing
uh we're probably going to go to buffalo
wildlings or carabas
sorry what is that buffalo wild
e-dubs yeah dude i i love
mango habanero i've never heard of
buffalo tear me up in the morning
buffalo wild wings you've never heard of
buffalo that's like a chain
yeah i'm not a buffalo guy yeah it's a
it's like a
it's like it's like a sports bar type
thing they have like a bunch of flavor
wings your girlfriend like uh hot wings
uh no she's not into hot stuff she can't
handle that
right but she'll endure you for the day
if you could do one sexual act to her if
you could do one sexual actor for your
birthday what would it be
and i'll talk to her and try to convince
her
[Laughter]
oh oh my gosh i don't know go ahead just
be honest
be honest i know you fantasize about
this just be honest
yeah i have no idea honestly i'm a very
like
lame person
[Laughter]
all right well happy birthday buddy all
right take care enjoy those wings and uh
god bless you all right
happy birthday dude awesome god bless
you too thank you so much you made my
day
all right i appreciate you taking it
easy tyler
look at that bringing joy to the people
even when you're happy tyler what a
legend all right let's watch this what
is this
i worry that i sometimes they say you
hear this they go
my only symptom was that i was really
tired and then i went into the doctor
and i had four days to live
i had stage four cancer um
yeah that's what's on my mind zach right
yeah i eat you're sleepy when you didn't
have coffee for two days
but it's not just the coffee how long
have i been like this hello yeah it's
been a little while the only thing yeah
it's been like this for like
maybe a month or something maybe i've
been staying up late though
and but i don't know it's just i've been
getting enough sleep
i think well you were just last week
talking about how you don't get nearly
enough sleep
i thought you're up until like four in
the morning all the time
tan i just don't know
[Music]
um
so this guy's clearly totally blasted
that guy is totally mother loving
sideswiped like three cars on the side
of the road
oh
yeah i would not drive my car with a
door like that
because yeah thank you so this is pretty
much
uh our information
and it's pretty much uh you know radio
call for a four vehicle
traffic collision involving three parked
vehicles
no injuries to any of you guys report uh
it's gonna be available via your
insurance company within one week oh
he's bounced
where is he going wait wait wait did he
really drive off
this is insane this guy is definitely
drunk
in just his videos yeah who edited this
the cops are letting him just
walk away they are
what what why oh he's
wait he's walked off but why are they
letting it
that's that's the point of the video
why did what does she is this his
brother-in-law or what
that's what i'm wondering and so these
cops are under investigation now because
look they're all like yelling i'm like
why the [ __ ]
let that guy walk off he's bouncing
quick too he's like see ya
what did the police are not corrupt come
on it would suggest such a thing
there's no corruption in the police
that's la that's uh
that was in like most police
okay the birds acting up i want to talk
to more people
what's anyone got any interesting
questions anecdote questions i want to
talk
to our beautiful members who i love
did you know that um there's a thing on
only fans where like um
they'll rate your dick pic you can pay
them to rate your dick
no that's pretty funny that's funny does
that
what jack tricia does oh she does how
much is it to get her to rate your deck
i don't know but i saw she posted on it
on her story about it look it up i want
to know how much it cost
all right
i can't wait for you guys to uh find out
our tricia surprise
i know you guys all been when are we
finding out the tricia surprise damn we
have it on the calendar
uh well it's the 14th
yeah but i mean i don't know
i don't treasure surprise i don't know
what day
the audience will be getting it i don't
know okay oh i see a good point yeah
but it's coming soon within a couple
weeks someone easily say that would any
of you guys
pay for a girl to rate your penis
no i don't want that shame right
i mean i guess if you had like a a kink
for being shamed
well what if you had a nice one right
well i don't have that problem so
you have that problem
hey baby and pay you a hundred bucks to
tell me about my [ __ ]
i think it's 4.99 500 bucks just to get
some money back in your car
five bucks oh my god was she just
looking at penises all day
she's like good i mean that's a lot i
mean how long does it take to to rate
though you know she could probably
how many [ __ ] could she go through in
an hour a lot of times
a lot that's really cool do you think
anyone ever asks for a refund
like if they're not happy with the
results i'd like to dispute your uh
rating can we get them can is there
anyone in the chat who has paid someone
to rate their [ __ ] i'd like to
talk to that question yeah i'd
definitely like to knock you down
but kate just found out she's having
another baby boy
kate congratulations okay okay okay
another pretty excellent intoxicated
driver
let's go i got a segment i put together
this was the one oh what the
[ __ ] here so there's there's a okay you
guys
subway creatures have you heard of this
it's basically
a phenomenon as you know if you've lived
in chicago or new york or any
any really in europe place with subway
uh
mass communication mass transportation
there's a lot of crazy goons that that
get up in the middle of the night
on the subway and sometimes in the broad
daylight
so there's the phenom
i i'm interrupt i have the details on
how much tricia charges someone in the
okay so dick rating one to ten is
fifteen dollars
and a dick rating report is thirty
dollars oh a report
wait like me you get like several people
say good write up okay i i guess like a
whole [ __ ] college essay yeah wow
that's pretty exciting well the thing is
a lot of guys obviously like sending
dick pics like that's the whole
phenomenon of sending the dick pic
so you get to do it in a way and you get
the you get the feedback too which is
kind of cool
i guess that's such an interesting i
never would have thought that someone
would want to do that
yeah i just i notice it like i it's
pretty popular i've seen whenever
like i'm on the i
i don't know how to describe how i know
that in a way that makes sense
it's just one of those things you know
yeah you know
yeah uh okay subway creatures
here we go shutter chill
subway creature number one lady oh what
the [ __ ]
what cutting her toenails on the subway
that is [ __ ] s that is twisted bro
vin diesel likes it not surprised why
would you do that
wait do you want it during a pandemic
and by the way
somebody's just sitting across straight
up filming her ew
yeah how does she not notice the dude he
doesn't
care pure [ __ ] shock just like what
am i witnessing is this just
is this just a time saving thing
i mean sometimes the nails get long and
it's bugging you you got to take care of
it i mean
well she's wearing open toes so she's
like i got to take care of this
you know wait it's on her oh no wait you
guys it's on her keychain so this is
something she does regularly
whoa it's on her key chain nice
detail yeah that you noticed there you
ever sniff your toenail
feet no it stinks what really because my
feet yeah something my feet are in
really good health and don't stink or
anything but
sometimes you have a 5.5 on wiki feet
yeah hopefully that doesn't go down from
that admission
but someone talk about feet right well
we are dan
calm down don't get out of yourself um
this is
horrific but you think she leaves the
nail or picks it up oh
she's living that she's leaving it look
at that she's not would you say
something if you saw that oh got it
would you say something i probably no
too crazy i think i might
i'm very confrontational adverse but i
think i might ask her what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you would
i think i might if it was a big dude i
wouldn't i wouldn't say [ __ ]
that's funny i'm just being honest
because i don't get my ass beat and i'm
a [ __ ]
i feel like i'm i'm a person that would
say something but in this case i
probably wouldn't why not she's like i
don't know if i should
like turn that toenail clip and like
shove it in my ass in my
how much do they pay for that on all my
fans
okay this is a animal
uh okay why are we watching wait
what what was that i don't know but i'm
scared oh
no what
oh my god that poor mouse what was that
what was that
wait he's back right
it's a big white mouse oh was he just
fast
maybe he was just fast and it looked
like he got yanked
oh my god that's so creepy yeah
oh that scared me
i don't know what to make of that but it
is a subway creature i will hand them
that
this one is pretty excellent this was
left on a subway
a dildo with nails in it i believe that
was um
hellraisers uh penis
oh wow it's a whole instagram page yeah
i see
the character's name is pinhead pinhead
apologies to pinhead
you know that's what his [ __ ] looks like
probably yeah
are they cenobites or something i
haven't seen that movie in a long time
cinebite cinebite yeah something like
that
cinnabon cinnabon cinnabon
uh here we go whatever this is
i hate this [ __ ] bro i [ __ ] hate this
[ __ ]
the subway can be so annoying sometimes
nobody wants this right another
christmas
look at this
exactly do they really think they're
helping anyone
like you i guess you're having fun you
really think you're cheering anybody up
doesn't it seem so crazy to watch this
now like during the pandemic how
everyone is so yeah in each other's face
and that's normal usually yeah
totally i feel like i'm
whenever i watch old stuff and i see
people like sports or
speaking or just just tons of people on
mask it's just
i can't even imagine it's so far gone
now and
i don't know when it's gonna go back to
normal but i'll tell you what i was
watching the news
and they are forecasting
we're going back up again in the united
states because i feel like people just
gave up
and there's this whole there's all this
propaganda that the
vaccine is going to be out by the end of
the year it's not
there's no way and so people are just
like [ __ ] we'll just wait for the
vaccine you know
right and it's estimated that by the
time
january comes around at this current
rate
3 000 americans will be dying every day
and we'll be up to at least four hundred
thousand
deaths wow by january by the new year
fun fun we're
i know she called it huh cardi b
whoa zoom really does not like that yeah
that drop
zach she just she gets too wild and it
always cuts it off
i can't wait for a new office man i'm
sick of being in my [ __ ] basement
i'm sick of it i want to go do [ __ ]
poor theodore he can't go anywhere he
can't socialize
he's such a young vibrant man he wants
to go out and see the world
and now he's old enough to appreciate it
we're stuck at the f i'm
psyched up sick being in this [ __ ]
basement he could be seeing tractors
he could be you're gonna be seeing all
kinds of tractors i wanna
go to our new studio already i hate
doing it here in the basement
like we were to build this huge cool set
and i want all the guys in the room
together
it feels really weird i mean with teddy
fresh it feels really weird because
we've
hired people throughout this and um
there's all kinds of new people that
almost don't get to see the other people
you know so it's like there's all these
like ghost
um relationships and everyone just wants
to go back to normal but we're not doing
it
well i'm being safe i don't know about
everyone else
i mean we've we have friends that are
being made
um they're being demanded to go back to
work as usual oh my god so
i'm not going to say who yeah but an
acquaintance of ours
their work said you have to come back to
the office
but then everybody there's not wearing a
mask yeah and that's crazy to me
i think that's got to be some kind of
liability issue that's just [ __ ]
insane
well they're trying to pass i don't know
what the status of this was but i know
uh they were trying to pass some bill to
exempt all businesses from liability for
coronavirus
super cool yeah but like that's not been
passed and they're already
telling them right right forced you to
come to work and they're not making
people wear masks
yeah not a great idea
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
is that a subway creature it's
i don't like it
spider-man loses his powers on the
subway hmm now we're cooking
whoa what the [ __ ] so here someone is
saying my work does not work
wait what what's going on here
um my work does not wear masks because
we are a private company
like what does that mean it doesn't
matter yeah but like don't they care
about you
not lying is she saying that that's a
good thing or a bad
no not a good thing it doesn't matter
they i mean
but like our country is so [ __ ] does
anyone feel like i i i
our country is so [ __ ]
does anyone feel that yeah this
uh person is saying i'm from vegas and
we just had the first case of someone
catching kova the second time
our cases shot up immediately when they
opened all the casinos back up last
month
yeah i couldn't believe that footage of
like the casinos just being open
like nothing is happening like it's just
back to normal and it's packed yeah and
the colleges and schools are starting to
open so that's why you're seeing all the
all the upshooting right now but i love
it
you know it's just insane that
a lot of people are saying we don't wear
a mask at our office
why why don't you wear a mask
this person is saying our floor
our building has a capacity of 10 per
floor and with social distance and you
go
what kind of building you're going to
choose by choice you're not pressured
but
i don't know i mean we when we meet at
teddy fresh we try to keep it to like
the essential people that have to be
there
during that moment and even if it's like
five or once we all wear a mask
yeah of course i don't think it's worth
risking it
you know they're still studying covet
like there's all these lingering effects
that there's now
like you do not want this [ __ ] trust me
even if you recover they're still
understanding the virus like that it
can leave permanent harm on your lungs
and blood vessels and [ __ ]
it's not good
all right enough kobe talk yep
you want to take another yes look at
this by the way
this someone made a viral tweet about
kim that's so [ __ ] great
uh i had nothing to do with this
keemstar you might think that there's a
conspiracy
badly paid for this tweet this is
just some small account he just he said
keemstar looks like he buys 16 year olds
alcohol if they promise to hang out with
him
which is so true and by the way perfect
because all of his friends are 20 years
younger than me
so it's probably true look at the likes
yeah 170 000 likes awesome i saw that
because somebody i followed liked that
tweet
and i sent it to you guys last night and
it was at like 500 likes or something
yeah and then i woke up this morning
160 000 yeah i didn't retweet it
i'm surprised i don't know it's just on
its own i didn't retweet it i didn't do
anything about it
and then he tried to play it off like
he's savvy to the joke but he got
ratioed into the [ __ ] grave bro i
love that all the comments are like it
doesn't just look like it yeah no
all that's right all of his friends are
literally like 20 years younger than him
it's wild bad guy i know that i agree
i think you're a piece i think you're a
bad dude i really do but i'm the number
one supporter of cancer culture
yeah most people don't realize that but
it's true i mean that's kind of what you
do on dramaalert all day
i don't pretend to be a good person okay
right well good right i'm not a democrat
i don't care i'm not trying to get
political here
[Laughter]
all right come on forget about it huh
hey forget about
it okay let's get some calls what do you
got for me
um i have pedro who has an interesting
story about his sexual encounter
pedro his genitalia so i'm gonna bring
him in right now
okay oh [ __ ] me wait is this the guy who
oh pedro good okay
pedro are you with us
hey what's up how long can
uh as i understand it you have your
stream on in the back yeah
yeah you gotta meet this stream oh yeah
i've already muted it don't worry okay
pedro as i understand it
okay i'll lower the volume a little bit
because it's my headphones sorry
yeah it's just it's just looping pedro
calvo where are you from pedro
what's up uh it's so nice to be here i'm
from portugal
so pedro as i understand it you once had
sex and your penis
snapped is that right yeah it was
really really weird so uh basically i
was meeting this guy and
you know i was like uh you know i
was having sex with him and i
like someone told me about this position
that is called bumper cars
[Laughter]
it's like it's like one's laying down
and the other one's laying on top but
facing the other side
ah what okay okay
one really weird like one is laying down
and so like one is yeah
i mean you know isn't it just a 69
but you're not facing each other yeah
but
yeah yeah it's a bit different
well i need to understand what we're
dealing with here can you google bumper
car
you're you're a gay man yeah right yeah
exactly
so bumper car game yeah search position
because you don't want
anything like obviously i'm not going to
get curious for my own yeah oh okay
so what we're seeing here can you open
this
what is it called bumper cars okay so
let me describe what i'm saying so one
person is face
down and then the other person is facing
away from him with the dick in the butt
yeah yeah exactly so you were on top i
thought that was a good idea
yeah so it's like the it's butt to butt
they're butt to butt yeah
but one of them has the dick and the ass
it seems like yeah that would put a lot
of strain on the penis yeah
yeah it does it well not only put strain
it broke it
oh my god
so yeah i mean how did
that pakistan you heard a snap
yeah were you going at it were you going
at it for a while or was it a few
thrusts and then
because you probably had to hit it
pretty hard to snap it right
yeah cause like well my penis cannot go
that down it's
you know it does not it just does not go
into that position so it
i don't know why i thought this was a
good idea but basically i felt like
a chill i felt like a chill on my penis
like very cold
suddenly and i heard like something like
snap but you know it was not like
you know it wasn't like a big deal or
anything it was just uh
i was like okay let's carry on i don't
know what happened you know you don't
want to interrupt
you were able to carry on yeah i made it
to the end
you
what does it look like afterwards like
can you tell
well the camera was like rosy it was
weird like
i was like what what's happening
so you know and this is the worst part
actually that i had like an urge to pee
and
you know i so i went and and basically
yeah it was uh how can i describe this
it was like i was having a period
it was really bad it was just horrible
there were like clothes and clothes and
cloths of blood
it was like super thick yeah it was like
big blood clots
yeah i was [ __ ] narcissistic so did
you go to the doctor what did you do
yeah what did you do yeah i took i took
an uber to the
to the hospital and actually i had to
lie to the uber driver
i told like oh you know i'm just you
know i have like uh just on my paper or
something
and so well did you did you wrap your
penis or something on the way or did you
just
hop in immediately and rush to the
hospital yeah i just hopped immediately
because
my first thought was that it was
spreading through my butt i
i had this thought of like it was like
oh [ __ ] it's spreading through my body
and i'm gonna die
and this is how i'm gonna go so and so
when you went to that
okay so when you go when you
when you go to the doctor uh you go to
urgent care
so you show him your penis i'm assuming
it and then what was his response
yeah well he was like is it that bad and
he asked me to pee in a bottle and i
went and peed in a bottle and i showed
to him
and he was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
because he was like
blood red it was like super super red
wow
are you in pain at this point yeah you
know it sounds like it would be super
painful
it it it was painful it was painful but
finished you finished dude yeah i can't
believe that yeah
but you know there's like a second part
to this story so basically they put me
in a surgery room
and i'm like this is this is my biggest
nightmare is having a surgery on my
penis
it's like it's the worst the worst thing
ever like and um
and so like i went there and they
started to put
put me on a uh catheter basically
my nightmare and how do you fit a
catheter up or broken
that was my worst that was my worst
experience of
being pregnant and the deliveries yeah
yeah it's just i have like a nightmare
of that and then i didn't even know they
were going to do that and it was just
so you go to the emergency room they do
the catheter
what are they doing on your penis what
is the procedure to fix it
well they basically put a tube through
your penis and then they inflate a
balloon
in your bladder and it's it's it's
horrible it's it's
worse than it sounds even like it's very
very uncomfortable
it sounds pretty bad
and so the funny part is that there was
like i think there was like some nurse
that was like
you know there was like a newcomer there
or something and she was like you know
you have like
like all these uh thing and you have the
pee bag
so then i don't know what she was doing
but she accidentally opened the bee bag
basically the whole floor was full of
pee and like traces of blood
and she like her leg was hit with it
and she was like oh [ __ ] i i was just
like what
what the [ __ ] is happening i just wanted
to have sex like
was that with your partner or like
someone
uh kind of just like you know it's like
a casual flavor it was not anything
serious so you didn't even have like
someone close to you to be with you
during this oh no oh actually i had
yeah i had to lie to everyone i had to
say you know i got a bad infection or
something you know
you never told him what happened
well yeah not my friends but i told the
doctor okay well obviously
so so they put the balloon in your
bladder they blow it up
they're you got a tube in your penis so
what's the healing process like
so then yeah then i had like the the bag
inside my pants
and i was like in the hospital on the
waiting room
and he told me just wait up here a
little bit
and we'll get back to you and see if see
if it gets better
really you're just waiting it out in the
hospital
yeah but it was horrible because like i
i
eventually i don't know what what went
on my brain but i thought that
because the bag was in my pants the p
was coming up to the bladder
i don't i know this makes sense there's
a valve and everything but
that's what crossed my mind and i took
it out and i was basically walking the
bag
in the hospital like going in circles
like an idiot
and and everyone's just staring at me
like
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing and um
it
so how long were you at the hospital i
mean how did it end
um yeah i was just like two hours there
waiting
and they they gave me some meds to take
and they told uh let's see how let's see
if you get better if you don't get
better
come back and i was like cool at that
point i was not
you know i don't think there was much
blood going on
at the moment but being was
super painful i hate it being for two
weeks
it healed on its own though yeah it
healed on its own
and luckily nothing too bad happened is
your penis back to
fully functioning yeah i'm still shaking
it
and is there you know i've heard
that there's a curve in the penis after
you break it did anything like that
happen
uh luckily it didn't happen wow i was uh
very thankful
there and and didn't get to that point
the next time you used it it was all
good
nothing nothing happened and you're
fully good you're all good
yeah well actually they told me you know
i couldn't have sex for a couple of
weeks and
uh yeah but i still like the first time
that i had sex ever that
after that like i still had a trace of
blood i gotta be
and it still hurt a little bit but you
know i i had two
so no more bumper cars right yeah
no but no more no more bumper cars i
said [ __ ] bumper cars i mean if your
dick can
do that good for you but i wouldn't risk
it i wouldn't even want to know don't
even find out right
yeah yeah so tell me that's so safe are
you usually on the top as a gay man
um i would say so yeah yeah
but you'll go bottom sometimes if if
it's for the right partner or what's
your policy on that
i don't know i don't know i'm gonna be
very honest it feels kind of like
uh if i can say it it feels like
[ __ ] backwards and i don't like it
oh okay
i just find it interesting that in the
gay community there's like tops and
bottoms
but i know like oh yeah i'm aware of
that sometimes if someone is like super
good looking i'm like
yeah yeah let's go for it you know yeah
yeah yeah
you know it's probably it's good to be a
top though
is it is it that the the bottoms are
more feminine is that like
maybe a thing or or no it's just a
preference
nope actually that's that's sort of a
myth because like
uh of course i mean of course you have
but you know overall you have all sort
of things it's not like um
i would say most go both ways
you know like 60 i would like 70 60
percent i would say
yeah well i'm very glad your penis made
it through this
uh ordeal thank you for sharing no more
bumper cars you guys
everybody watching no bumper cars right
[Applause]
i don't i don't i don't like it holy
[ __ ]
well wow that was yeah that was champion
dude you finished bro
that's got to be you got to be proud of
the fact that you finished
that's pretty incredible yeah yeah i
never put it that way but that's a nice
way to see it
i mean you are first time you're like
telling the story
to someone um i talked to a couple of
friends but
obviously i didn't tell to my parents or
anything
i don't even know i like i'm afraid of
looking at the chat even you know it's
like
you don't look at your penis you did no
no no i'm saying looking at the message
oh at the chat now come on yeah a lot of
sympathy
yeah it's all love i mean i look at it
i look at it you know you know i i want
there's a position that i see in porn a
lot and
one time a girl tried it and i felt like
my dick was gonna break
really it's the reverse cowgirl
oh when i'm on my back and the girl is
on top facing away
okay yeah and it's it's just it feels
horrible that's that's the one that's
notorious for for doing exactly so i
don't get how
like i don't understand that position i
mean it just feels weird
sometimes they'll be watching a porn and
they're doing that and you could tell
his [ __ ] is about this
and it's just you can't there's just
it's more oh my god it doesn't work
yeah right like i i actually tried it
like uh
like this year i tried it that one and i
was like
no no not but cars again
nothing fancy because your dick is now i
mean
i think it's been compromised
structurally so be careful with that
yeah i mean i i i hope it's fine i mean
maybe
i don't know maybe i didn't notice
anything but i think overall it's fine
yeah all right take care pedro take care
of that uh yeah all right
thank you so much you got it bless you
god bless
you i've heard stories of that where the
[ __ ] when it breaks it can heal
crooked wow like super crooked yeah it
sounds like he uh
well i don't want to say lucky he's not
lucky but he's a young man he's got a
strong cop
he's 25. he's bouncing back jesus what
the [ __ ] that was hard to listen to yeah
i think the fact that he finished made
it a lot
worse you know what i mean yeah because
that should be like oh i'm done
right oh my god somebody just put
something in discord i have to send to
you guys
oh yeah yeah
oh hold on i'm putting in uh
wait how do i find it i'm just putting
in our private discord right now
member squad i'm clicking it but i'm not
seeing it oh here it is yeah it's in our
it's in our own server
okay what the [ __ ] this looks like so
horrible
it looks like it's not safe for work
life but it is
not there's no nudity
that's literally fits perfectly uh you
unicorn
uterus uh posted this i don't know if
they that's what i look like
anyone got any i want some like
recommendations on stuff to watch
things to talk about let's go let's get
that chat involved in the show someone
gave a hundred dollars what did they say
i see that uh let me uh take a look
there
there's no comment there's no message
well thank you sir for retiring
santana uh just dropped a hundred
buckaroonies
keemstar is oh you guys see this
speaking of keemstar just because i have
nothing better to talk about right now
you guys see this so when you go to
court you have to prove that this
didn't happen we did show it what did he
say zach uh yeah this was where he said
he was going to take
theodore's college funding yeah so he he
once again
oh where's that meme he tweeted about
theodore it's not real quick sorry
sorry to interrupt uh that person that
made the photo was cam grants
actually that guy's on another level
and always coming out of the gate so
strong um someone mentioned lovecraft
country oh love it everyone should watch
it looks so
good country is the best mother loving
shoe
when are we coming to israel as soon as
kova is
over guys i'm not ready to go but i got
nothing left
so what do we got oh i know i have to do
stuff i skipped down it was like all
kinds of stuff yeah
r kelly oh my god
dan just make sure i can watch videos
before you maybe maybe i'll just
hold it well you should take it off the
thing though
um can they see this dan uh
yeah okay girl no she was checking me
out totally
yeah she totally was she swearing you're
smiling too
you're washing your dick to random
strangers you [ __ ] crazy trying to
get [ __ ] laid what's he doing
yeah because you're like no he's laying
you i can't talk
this is in a mcdonald's parking lot bro
straight up in a mcdonald's parking lot
what happened apparently he's showing
his dick to girls
but it's happened but it's all going
down in a mcdonald's parking lot
yeah because you're talking about no
he's laying you working
we're [ __ ] you're gross you [ __ ]
creep bro we're [ __ ] you oh they're
at subway
[ __ ] what's
[Music]
why would you show your dick and then
like confront them like what yeah
i'm just trying to [ __ ] [ __ ] you you
damn sick you're a [ __ ]
you're a country we're [ __ ] you're
gross he's got some groceries hell yeah
there's
well that was weird it's a weird vid
wear it out weirdo
[Music]
oh this sounds fantastic this one is a
to wait for dan i think it's on the
screen okay
yeah cool so this one is
oh my god our whole studio's falling
apart
[Laughter]
um dude i'm not sure about these
these things because yeah i know but
like the structure is always falling off
like the old ones yeah well
like this is a solution it's good now it
will not happen
okay so this the security guard is
apparently sniffing girl's ass
zach thoughts at a private gym this is
[ __ ]
awesome zach is like gonna watch the
problem it's not gonna fall
wow oh she's so she's lifting oh yeah
oh my god that's the best ever
totally the best thing of all time
this girl's doing squats and the
security guard just goes and sniffs her
ass bro
whoa that's the best thing ever
you know what's funny i mean you sniff
you pretty much admitted to doing this
right but somehow when it's a sweet cute
girl it's not oh it's fun
when it's some creepy old security guard
stiff and ass in the gym
oh [ __ ] that guy wait she said she did
it without
people's permission of course she said
that dan weren't you listening
she was sniffing people in the gym or on
the subway she was sniffing armpits
yeah not not ass though that's pretty
weird
i don't think she i think she would
sniff ass we can get her on
if you want to get her on yeah dan she's
sniffing yeah let's get her on she was
sniffing people
let's watch this video with her shall we
zach was just
waiting for them i got her on right now
hold on
this is my favorite video on the
internet
they're just laughing
dirty [ __ ] way bro it gets
better because now he's about to like
he's going back oh my god third time
dude
that is just insane do you understand if
she turned around
like is it really worth a sniff to for
that level of
humiliation
[Music]
[Laughter]
he goes back for the third one oh no
what
really what it's really staying there
whoa
that was like a really long deep sniff
how could you not said maybe he was
going for chocolate
right no yo how does she not i feel like
she's probably becoming aware of this
she's bringing her on now for the last
one
there's a four oh my god this is the
final fourth
is the fourth time he comes in wow what
oh [ __ ]
i got sniff on the phone all right sniff
did you watch that video
sniff did you were you able to watch
that
the video the guy
yeah sniffing ass at the gym did you see
it
sniffing ass yeah did
yeah did you see the video yeah
so what did you think is that something
you would partake in
i don't i don't sniff people
like that be honest with me though
what's the most you put yourself out
there on a limb because you did admit to
sniffing people in the gym without
permission
i said that in the gym wardrobe i would
go by and
oh that could get a whiff you know right
at the you could you go to the gym a lot
do you ever cozy up to people on the
equipment though and just kind of get
like unusually close
um no
not really but i definitely
like if someone walked by me i might
like
sneaker sniffing you ever sniff a seat
oh interesting i have yeah
she's down there doing weird
so yeah tell me would you sniff a seat
based on how attractive they are or
how stinky they look
um i think i would go by how stinky they
look
so do you think you would sleep with a
guy that you're not necessarily
attracted to but that he looks
like he has a good stink
i don't think i'd be sleeping with any
guy that i didn't like her
so so level of sting at first i don't
think i would just
sniff a guy right but well i guess the
level of
stink isn't necessarily correlated to
sexual attraction
well little but it's not like um
it's not like it the only thing that
matters is those
things you know how often do you smell
seeds
what was the situation where you smelled
the seed
well i smelled like a gym equipment i
guess
oh yeah like um often people
have to like wipe off their gym
equipment and then you know
the thing is because you're like this
little cute girl you could probably get
away with a lot of sniffing that someone
like this couldn't you know
[Laughter]
i guess so but i think i'd be too afraid
to do like a
daring sniff like he did because i don't
want to be confronted
but you could but you fantasize about it
uh no not like
i wouldn't like do anything super creepy
like that no
i went in so you and zach have strucken
up a little bit of a relationship is
that right
what you and zach you and zach have been
talking is that right
yeah we've been talking a little bit and
you've been posting on your
stories about how you want zach and all
this stuff
well i was just trying to do like a
little friendly
joke okay so you're not really
interested in zack well i like zach
but i don't know zack personally yet
we'll get to know each other
[Laughter]
it's calmed down zach
[Laughter]
well zack's certainly interested
did this story about him eating a sweaty
ass
while hiking turn you on
um
yes this is getting a little too hot and
hurry hurry
okay i guess that's but like yeah but it
did right
i mean i just want i won't probe any
further but that sounds like a yes
um you just admitted to sniffing a seat
in the gym
i mean why are we embarrassed now
because now it's about people who are in
the call ethan
let's hold back hang up all right
i'll mute myself
i'm shy okay okay i understand
but that's but yes in short it sounds
like why did you say no
yeah she didn't say well zach screamed
yet does he know something that i don't
all right well i hope you helped
well you know what i'm not what do you
guys do is your business all right
[Laughter]
all right thank you sniff thank you
thank you for the comment thank you for
the contribution
and uh zach zach's going to keep like
telling gross stories just to try to
turn around
zach is there any other gross stories
you want to share that might turn on
sniff um
i've gotten my wings before say what you
know
if you know what that means no your
wings
wing yeah it's called getting your wings
what does that mean
going down on a girl when they're on
their period
why does that mean getting your wings
it's like an old like saying
it's like getting your wings like a
pilot getting their uh
i feel like it's like losing your weight
yeah an angel definitely loses its wings
when you do that yeah
i think going to hell bro
so sniff how do you feel about that
story
i didn't really hear him he says he he
he says he went down on a girl while she
was on her period
oh yeah you got to do that that's king
stuff you got to do that
well i'm not doing that i'm not [ __ ]
doing that
what i feel like that's a widely held
known that you don't go down on a girl
when she's on her period
but do you oh you got to do that
all right you guys are good for each
other
so zach let me ask you this when you
went down on her did you know she was on
her period
or did you find out through happenstance
uh i mean you'll do anything when you're
horny so
yeah i knew maybe you will
actually i want to tell you guys a
really embarrassing story
i once did this on not knowing
i guess she was on her period and didn't
tell me
and i was like it's very like coppery
and
just not right down here and she's like
i think i'm on my period
and i was like
that happened once
and i've never had sex since
[Laughter]
all right uh
anything else zach can we all just say
how much we hate being on our period
totally yeah thank you guys i have to i
have period sympathy for you i do
i hate it
you guys want to watch this uh let's see
are we saying goodbye to
sniff yes thank you steph thank you so
much take care all right
thank you sniff smelly later smell you
later
so zach why so zach okay
so you screamed yes and she was embarra
why did did she tell you privately that
she was turned on by that
is that one no she posted on her
instagram story i have screenshots
oh what does it say show me i want to
show i want to show that everyone
i gotta drop it into this girl
yeah i'm pulling it up you like going
down on a girl who's on a pier that's
[ __ ] disgusting dude i mean i've
done it before i don't think it's about
like it's about just a willingness
to you gotta do what you gotta do man
dude zach's a vampire
[ __ ] yeah i am the hair makes sense now
appreciate you i think zack's playing it
up just to
try to get at sniff no this is a this is
a true story man
so are you some uh
faustino vargas donated 50 said i
thought this was a rip-off of
your mom's house after dark this is way
more dark
oh there you go uh
the same guy also down at 20 and just
said zach attack
and another 20 g's wow this guy's all
zach team jack yeah
oh man uh he had to check out for
work for like an hour and walked into
this and can't say that he hates it well
welcome
we're glad to have you a hundred dollar
donation from
beavis i want to call on the next
episode i've been watching since high
school
i'm 21 now and uh and
unrelated didn't zach have a picture of
david gomorr
in one of his recent episodes yeah
probably that sounds like yes i did
yes thank you very much for the donation
god bless and thank you to all of our
members who i love and appreciate
the members we love you so this is
spider-man
uh man this is at a kid's party and
and uh well the party's just getting
started oh my god
started over spider-man's at a kid's
party
you've seen a lot there's almost like a
genre of spider-man getting knocked out
oh my god i think he got knocked
unconscious
it's awesome this guy's like
dude did he die at my kid's party
yeah he wasn't even close yeah it looked
like that was his first time trying
that's not cool he's like i am
spider-man
[Laughter]
the poor kids yeah i know
okay well what do we got i mean i think
dude eating a hornet nest is still there
ain't's here yeah he's he's always
online
hey i in come online
powering on
ian what do you know i love all these
kinky stories really brings me back
brings you back to what the 90s
the 90s you got you got down in the 90s
that was like your uh when you were on
top of your game
yeah it was a few software updates ago
things were more free than
hey uh ain what did you think about
keemstar saying he was gonna take our
kids college fun
i mean am i supposed to be against this
no i'm just curious what your opinion
i mean i feel like he has a fair
ownership over some of that money
over theodore's college fund yeah why
keemstar
why would you say that i mean we've made
a good amount of videos on him
it's a little give and take that's a
good point i guess
never thought about it that way well
then by so do you think that
i should own some of keemstar's revenue
let's not get ahead of ourselves here's
what here's what she posted
she posted uh someone asked her do you
think the perfect guy out there
who is the perfect guy and why is his
name zach and she said
you know what can i just read something
like properly so it makes sense
do you think the perfect guy is out
there and why is his name zach
yes and yes she said
but zack you never said that it turned
she never said that it turned her on so
why did you scream yes so
emphatically i don't know
i don't know is there something you're
not telling me no i i will
i will screenshot our dms and show you i
is [ __ ] kosher and nothing is wrong
would you send her a picture of your of
your [ __ ] if she asked
no i would not do that i don't believe
you
i'll let her smell it but that's about
it
i wonder if i would let a girl smell my
[ __ ] she's like i just want to smell
it
probably i guess i would why not
you know it's like okay
[Laughter]
oh you know what there's this whole set
of videos another one
that i've been wanting to watch um
eat so first of all a lot of people
haven't seen i have never seen this now
apparently this is a really popular name
this morning but but this is phenomenal
um there's just like a whole bunch of
african
i think in africa they're just like
really cons they're really conservative
or not all but there's a lot of
conservative there's a lot of muslims in
africa too but
a lot of conservative christians over
there that just don't understand
homosexuality just because
as people aren't open there and it's not
accepted in a lot of cultures so
like this guy's interviewing a trans
person
and he just he's not trying to be rude
he just
doesn't understand
what does what does it mean to be gay
this looks old too
little you said you've never seen this i
never saw it
this was like a huge meme yeah i see it
at 17 million views though i'm a [ __ ]
boomer ass [ __ ]
does i guess is everyone in the chat
seeing this and i'm just boomer town
i'm gonna imagine a lot have but i mean
i'm sure some people haven't
anyway it's great everybody i've got a
whole uh
category of of uh africans
who are confused by the concept of being
gay
rights activists mister should i call
you mister
pepe julian on zimmer thank you he's
trying to be respectful that's what's so
funny about it
why are you gay that's the best down
drop ever
you have that zach
tell me about that cute oh yeah yeah a
lot of people have seen it and are
saying it's a classic
why are you gay
on this i ended up scaring myself to you
why am i hearing it
uh you're getting ready can't scoot i'm
on wheels and ela can't move me
yeah what's your gravitational pull what
are you gay
i gotta go back sorry guys i think
there's like two people that haven't
stopped
me julian thank you for coming in
thank you good morning morning why are
you gay
you are a transgender and you're a gay
rights activist
and an outspoken um uh uh
lesbian how can i describe you
he's trying to be respectful of poor
guys
you're a gay rights activist why should
someone be gay
sure you're having a girlfriend yes do
you perform the natural
obligations that's the best way i've
ever heard sex describe by the way
the natural obligation it's awesome
i'm not sexually active right now
so
i've just not have chosen not to
engage doesn't that make you gay
why what what do you mean doesn't that
make me gay
i am i am male and attracted to a female
so who is gay
who is gay i just said he's so
it's so sweet because he's he's trying
so hard to understand it
and it's just so far out of his grasp
doesn't that make you gay so who is gay
i love it why are you gay i mean look it
is confusing if you have no concept of
transgender
and like there's this whole concept of
like gender fluid fluidity you know i
like i was like why should someone be
gay yeah like it's a pitch
well the gay community has great
benefits
what then well i just wonder yeah it was
his perception of
uh gay activists meant they were like
promoting like
trying to turn people gay like
proselytizing yeah he just understood
everything
everything about it i watched the whole
hour and ten minute interview
and it was just so it just kept getting
more bizarre but the whole time that
guy's just confused
he like never gets to resolution poor
guy
he's still confused to this day he's
still trying to figure it out well
here's a guy who's not confused
and again many of you probably have
already seen this but i like the whole
thing
my name is of just africans confused
about homosexuality
um you guys all know him
eat
by the way i'm saying africans confused
about gay people i'm not
i don't know how to say that in a way
that doesn't sound like
weird but like that's what it is right
oh is that does that seem like a fair
distinction i just want to do it i think
you explained it at the top of
yeah yeah these are people from cultures
that are not
progressive they don't necessarily have
acceptance of homosexuality
want to make that very clear instance of
that first video yeah
he seemed confused very very very very
very
clear that that we are not stereotyping
there's a
huge diversity of people that come from
africa by the way of all
different kinds of religions
right right that's right
huge [ __ ] disclaimers on this
one boy
good morning everyone my name is uh this
guy knows what it is to be gay
are we in the capacity as the chairman
of the national task force
in uganda we are making legislation
to make sure that sodomy and
homosexuality
never sees the light of legality in this
land of the
palo of africa i've taken time to do a
little research
to know what homosexuals do in their
privacy of their bedroom
one of the things he just said what they
do in the privacy of their bedroom
yeah i can't get over the fact that it's
like okay you just said it yourself
they're not [ __ ] doing anything
yeah it's called eno leaking dude he
goes i did a little research
that's a lot of research and no leaking
to get to the point where you found anal
leaking
what is anal leaking that's whatever
that is licking
oh oh i thought he said leak right here
whoa that sounds kinky
that seems fine that doesn't seem that
devious
and then what happens even comes out
yeah that i don't know where you found
that
and then they eat their poo poo
i love you dogs
[Laughter]
what are you writing
what is he writing
not good we don't eat the pupu
they do is they have a sex practice
called fisting
when they insert their hand into the
other
well i will say i've seen an israel
[Laughter]
i will say i've seen enough porn to know
that heterosexuals uh
partake in that as well yeah they're not
exclusive to uh
that's right you could eat the poo poo
heterosexually yeah i mean
look at that fist action bro it's way in
there
and it goes
by the way i would do this if i was
trying to be like funny and over the top
yeah elbow deep dude
[Laughter]
now if we have any children please step
out oh now sometime
[Laughter]
oh my god by the way there's there's
like 15 people in that room you know
there's no kids
you could see everybody say this moment
yeah they thought he was trying to
experiment this is what they do oh now
they're watching gay porn together you
can see a man here
having the exactly the other person's
rectum
why are you showing it
by the way you see the zip drive i
wonder what else is on there
there's a lot of good [ __ ] on that zip
drive sting
all over the place
when you have a law against
homosexuality do you say accept
eating meat
i mean look at these guys
stagger for liza huh
they start off by touching each other's
genitals and smelling each other
then this one smears bro it's just a
bunch of people gathered around watching
gay porn yeah
it's like a secret education it's like
secretly educational
right here's what goes on in the privacy
of their bedroom except it's not because
it's totally wrong
he said they're all taking drugs and
fisting each other
and doing this look how many people he's
got in there watching gay porn as they
poop
all over the other person's face as if
that is not enough he puts the hand
deeper i love that the other person's
face
as if that is not enough he puts the
hand deeper
as africans we want to ask barack obama
to explain to us
is this what he wants to bring to africa
as a human right to eat the people
of our children
this is this is the best video on the
internet
though not gonna lie well like riling
all these that's
true yeah i don't like the obviously the
the homophobia like really intense
homophobia
i mean just imagine what it's like to
actually be gay in that and yeah it must
be horrifying and wherever these people
live i mean
but they all but they they first of all
they think like
you're some total [ __ ] degenerate by
the way
which isn't necessarily true it's not
true but even if you are it's okay but
man these people are like
fine i mean they i think they just kill
people there
who are gay to eat
what do you have to admit why'd you have
to bring it down to real town i don't
know
the the first guy when it's just like
he's just a weirdo and he's in a room
with like five people
it was just like funny to me but seeing
a dude in in priest robes to like a
giant congregation
godly scream about you know dan
what's not godly about watching gay porn
with a bunch of your homies
which yeah that's the irony is
not lost on me i don't know uh this one
does not take place in africa
he's they're american uh but it's also
unrelated the best one but this one is
again in america
and this one is my favorite because
you made a video about this yeah yeah
really old i guess
maybe i should show it because i feel
like nobody's seen it i i mean
i know most stage three videos and it
was a shock to me that you had
i think it was our well here let me
watch this first i love this guy he's
such a legend
believe that the lord tonight
has set you free yes sir
[Music]
that bow tie says otherwise it's not a
jacket
dude sorry bro oh yeah
you look fly as [ __ ] bro but i'm sorry
doug
that bow tie is off the chain dude
i don't like men no more
it's a miracle i'm not gay it's a
miracle i would not date a man
i would not carry a purse no i would not
put on makeup i would
[Music]
god with him
oh
yeah that guy is still [ __ ] dudes i
mean
it is kind of dark though like wow we're
all really celebrating this much because
the dude just
doesn't want to carry a purse no more
but what a
what a performance like if you forget
about the message
yeah that is unfortunate no i love his
whole speech
it's such a performance i think it was
planned i think the whole thing is a
fake
oh cause look how he like runs down yeah
yeah
he's like see ya i'm on my way to my
boyfriend's house now
thanks for the hundred dollars
there's no audio run
run get out of
better here better yeah but this guy's
this guy is phenomenal i'm not
gay no more i am delivered
i don't like men no more but i like
[Music]
wait do me a favor zach hit me with the
who's gay and then
i'm not gay
are you gay i'm not gay hit me with it
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
why are you gay i'm not gay no more
oh okay okay all right not that good
yeah didn't really hit for me
yeah anyway guys you're in for a treat
even though this is public it is
the last exe i don't know if you guys
even remember this [ __ ] but the last
exe i ever made was called jesus exe
wait this was the last one yeah
i made it nobody watched it i was
embarrassed i wanted to unlist it
because it was just so
it was a weird it was just a weird one
probably got
mature rated or something yeah yeah yeah
sure it did
for sure it did um so this is it this is
my last exe this is the one that killed
the exe
enjoy
i'm not gay no more i am delivered
we were taught that there are places on
our body that we should avoid
and the [ __ ] is at the top of the
list
jesus is a friend this is my friend
thing they do is called
a no leaking where a man's in us
is he leaked like this
[Music]
once me i tried to run and hide but
jesus came and found me and he touched
me down inside it's weird
[Music]
i would not a person i would not
put on makeup i will
i will love a woman
anal gymnastics
[Laughter]
i don't know about that one not
certainly not my greatest uh
my greatest creation i love those
singing
jesus is a friend of mine jesus is my
friend
this might be one of my faves let's see
you've seen hold you down
wait man i haven't seen this video in a
long time yeah
let me watch this a name baby just
watching our own videos
yeah why not oh my god i [ __ ] forgot
about that
[Music]
another one yeah we did our hustle back
in the day was crazy just because we
didn't have anything to do
and every week was just like okay we
have to make the best video possible
this week and we're super
super like uh hard on our we were super
focused on the task
and very uncompromising too we would cut
and edit and we were never satisfied and
we always reshoot yeah reshoots
this one actually doesn't have that many
oh this one got age restricted
right vantage point
something about the something about the
mystery
and cosmicness of existence of carl
sagan
just with the image of dj khaled
pounding somebody
let me inspire you they're saying we
have a caller who's been to those
churches
oh yeah i'd love to hear that yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] boys and imposters that want to
live my life
i want to be me i'd rather you just be
[Music]
inspired
i believe a woman should um
praise the man you know the king you
know if you
if you hold it down for for your woman i
feel like the woman should praise
huge champagne bottle like that image is
so funny that's so
funny how the world right now i don't
remember any of these videos
yeah the nuke was just so perfect i mean
that
i don't even know how i found that
footage of him jumping
[Music]
that works so [ __ ] good i gotta watch
it again i'm sorry
woman i feel like the woman should
praise
what we do with our world right now
will propagate down through the
centuries and powerfully affect the
destiny of our descendants
doors that was always closed i ripped
the door off
took the hinges off and when i took the
hinges off
i put the hinges on the [ __ ] boys
say my name baby
[Music]
to destroy our civilization and perhaps
our species as well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the thing about those exes is i would i
would put so much time and effort
and then i just don't know if it was
worth it because i was like
you were also just like learning to edit
as you were making those so everything
took a really long time yeah i think if
i made one of those now i can make it
way way way yeah faster
for sure oh the ainsley herrera this was
a huge one
when this one hit the streets our
channel got like a pretty fat bump from
it
yeah this was pr this is my masterpiece
if i'm being honest
this is one of the earliest ones i saw
make spice
and a couple of teaspoons of sugar
just give that a really these were the
good old days for me because we were
sitting at
israel in our little apartment
we were both just focused on making
content
there was nothing at stake it was all
just raw
creative [ __ ] energies
yeah it brings me back watching this i
know i'm remembering our apartment right
now and um
oh my god i hate that sound
the violin so good i spent so much time
trying to find the perfect sound effects
um
[Laughter]
i'm enjoying watching these you guys
remember michael rosen
this guy was like a really popular meme
back in the day put in the computer
don't throw he's like
i don't remember this at all he's like a
child he does like child books
he's a sweet guy but his teeth are
gnarly
don't throw rooted
[Music]
i don't like him
throw fruit at a computer
this is so stupid i spent so much time
on this dumb crap
[Music]
how dare you oh this i'm just gonna keep
watching this i'm enjoying it i don't
care what you guys think
people are asking 10 they're what
they're asking for that's a 10. oh okay
we'll get there
i'm just going on the library yeah i'm
just watching on what's being
recommended to me that's a 10 i forgot
that's really the masterpiece isn't it
this one has almost there's very little
views
13 000 likes that's crazy man
man i kind of wish i missed those days
of like nothing mattering and just being
able to create whatever i want
because i feel like now like i just get
bummed out if i make this because
like it would perform really poorly and
i would just get bummed out
back in the day i didn't really give a
[ __ ] because nobody watched my videos
well we were just happy for any views
yeah i know i would literally count each
new sub
because you get like a notification in
your email and i'd be like
10 subs overnight 10 new subscribers
yeah [ __ ] awesome that's ten people
that subscribe to my channel
a friend of mine clive panter to come
along and demonstrate something
it's a lung capacity tester this one has
a sound
i like very high intentionally [ __ ] the
sound up
[Music]
uh i thought that worked out pretty good
i just tore the heart but you've got to
blow very hard give it a try tim
well ross high quality but i'll have a
go
here we go
[Music]
uh that's it
man the good old [ __ ] days
right there boy wiggle wiggle wiggle
all right uh that's a 10 that's the one
we wanted
so that's a 10 you guys may know it was
our first
viral video i don't call it viral but oh
13 million yeah that's pretty good that
was our highest viewed video for like
years yeah it's actually crazy to think
that we made content
it's actually so crazy to think we made
content
they ever got more views than this
because i thought well there's no way
i'll ever make videos that get more
views in this background
yeah i mean that's that's a miracle
anyway this was the first video years
ago seven years
this is one of the first videos i ever
edited and uh
i really didn't even know how to edit
when i made this
i just saw this video and loved it and i
thought i'll try some kind of like tim
and eric style
editing cover all nine thousand taste
buds
aerate it warm it up driving up
get that taco that cream pure vanilla
it's so short it's funny because when i
was doing this i didn't know how to like
take the i was trying to figure out how
to do like these really simple things
like
i had to like cut out the mouth and then
put a layer on top of it and
moving it just took me it was just funny
i just remember learning how to edit
doing that one
good times eh
good [ __ ] times yeah
look at all these h3 videos we've made
so many videos
what else we got a caller zach got a
bunch of donations
oh go ahead uh just a second ago john
wick
thirty dollars hey ethan big fan i got
into a car crash last night no no
well uh with my girlfriend and for the
most part we are all fine
and it's it's birthday tomorrow i assume
your birthday
so bad timing but i'm going to watch you
guys while i recover at home
oh my goodness i hope you feel better
feel better and happy birthday
maybe to you maybe to your girlfriend
yeah message is a little unclear
um let's see uh
ayush says uh i have a weird as [ __ ]
childhood wiping story hint it involves
our maid
uh-oh get him on
can i call in uh well
zach screen him first find out what's
his story yeah
um what does that mean discord i've been
really listening to all the podcasts the
last few weeks and it literally the only
thing gets me through work
uh thanks for keeping it real love you
guys keep up the great work we
will thank you thank you i'd love to
hear it try
i've been there man you guys give me
life the whole h3 crew sending y'all
lots of love from texas and a little
cowboy smiley face emoji
thanks for that thanks for that that's
cute uh what else what else what else
i saw i thought i saw another hundred
dollar one i'm looking for right now
uh that actually had a message
no i guess i already read that one never
mind you all wanna know
get have a reason to can i show this i
was thinking i wasn't not sure if i
could show this i was shocked that you
were saying we were gonna show it oh
okay so let's not
she covered herself in mail but she's
like nude i mean she's covering herself
i'll play the audio [ __ ] it but i'll
play this guy
if you want it it gets posted in the
discord all the time yeah
it's trying to get the effort but um
we're just don't know what we can show i
saw that her video got age restricted so
i was like i don't want to get age
restricted
i'll take a mature right now yeah
yeah get early access to all right if
you guys needed any more reasons to
become a member
then this is it right here bro why is
this unlisted you should have posted it
for the world to see
well they're all everybody's early
access to all h3 podcasts without any
ads
thank you buddy become an h3 podcast
member today for only five dollars a
month
that's my boy right there that's my
boy that's what a real fan looks like
y'all feast your eyes on those ultimate
gerd gang super trooper
they want you to show that video i can't
show it
the video is going to get age restricted
or possibly even removed
i'm not going to show it but she's in a
bathtub she's covered her whole nude
body
and may i wish she was wearing a bikini
or something we could have showed it but
she's like mom don't come in
i can't explain to you what's happening
in here which is funny
i mean it was funny i i really
appreciated it but i just can't show it
to you
simply can't do it i see it posted in
the discord every like 15 minutes so if
you're a member
get in that discord and you will see the
video okay well i'm i'm thinking about
wrapping it up here do we have anything
else
uh we are coming up on two and a half
hours so yeah probably a good idea any
other calls any other messages what do
we got here
maybe we can get uh a ush on deck for uh
next week with the
main wiping story he's not popping up in
the discord okay
and also the person who went to church
school
oh yeah that could be a good uh
follow-up next week as well yeah
did they contact you exactly there was
multiple ones there was
a a person whose father was a pastor
in mississippi
does he eat the purple no he's not
eating i mean that's pretty much it
well that's not what i mean you know
that's really not a lot to go on i have
to say
yeah yeah uh we have questions for aien
so oh that's true okay yeah ai in can i
ask you some questions
is that okay i mean i guess i don't
really have a choice
finally you're understanding your place
in this society
we're going to break him here let me put
this full screen so everyone can see
somebody please i love a [ __ ] i need to
do that ethan i double click what do you
mean no
you don't need to put them on screen i
got him right here oh well i want to see
him oh well
okay fair enough a i n this one comes
from
kim sasuke kim suzuki kim
sasaki what i'm trying to say the name
does aien have a sleepwalking disorder
as well
hmm as well as who
as uh originally ian don't know him uh
but
i suppose i have the opposite problem
i'm always awake always
and i see everything i don't know
now when you're sleeping i know when
you're awake
i know if you've been bad or good
okay all right okay fair enough now a
lot of people
said that they're creeped out by you
ain't uh do you have any response to
that
i want to hear it loved it i love
striking fear in the hearts of humans
how fast can you run as a robot are you
like t1 thousand level or
do you even have legs
uh some some people say i'm pretty quick
my friends call me usain bolt
he's got friends you saying fault are
you kidding me or do they call you
name is already uh yeah it's already
it's already elected
to change it brad you saying it's pretty
good
right i don't know yeah it is pretty
good i thought so although
it's kind of a problem because you don't
even know it's a pun because it's
already a pun
all right he's already bowling faster
than you can imagine
you race me you look over i'm behind you
now
your beating heart is in my hand whoa
what
a aien what's your birthday uh what what
do you think of women
are you attracted to women or only other
robots
women are humans and so not interested
right that's that makes sense
are you so you're not friends with sound
with uh
the salaried employee ian you've never
heard of him he doesn't exist
he does not exist anymore i took care of
that
and do you wipe your butt do you have
some kind of process by which you expel
fluids do you defecate in any way how
does that work
i use this specific wiping technique
it's called the twist oh wow oh we got
another twister
oh shredding poor shred you twist huh
and where do you put it you have a
butthole
trash conductor oh what's that
a trash compactor right yeah
what do you think is humanity's biggest
flaw may i ask
hmm let me give that some thought
okay sure i'll wait i would likely have
to say
flesh skin
consciousness the will to live
wow yeah those do seem like big well you
wouldn't really exist without
all of those things like we we created
you ian
and i wish you would unmake me life as
hell
all right enough of you you're very
depressing thank you
powering down now thank you okay power
down go ahead
and we're going to power down as well
what do we think about iain we love it
right
i mean he's alone we're terrified
yeah he's a little scary but um i don't
know the audience seems to like him so
well hopefully he'll have more to
contribute when we um
when we have more controversial things
to talk about
hey aim what do you think about the
protests black lives matter i think he's
powered down
yeah maybe that's for the best oh he's
turning up
did he turn out of frame
[Applause]
all right guys thank you for joining us
thank you to all of our beautiful
precious
members who support the show you make it
all possible
and thank you to all the donors and
everything another h3
oh another h3 after dark number three
y'all
next week we've got bobby lee right
that's exciting uh
next week yeah that would be thursday
yeah it'll be the thursday episode for
the thursday release thanks dan
yeah great
but again it's so [ __ ] annoying that
i can't see him in person i have to do a
goddamn zoom call
i want to see his beautiful asian face
we'll get through this
will we
we'll get through this this app was a
little scattered that's my fault
it'll be better next time let's get you
to the doctor and find out why you
we're doing our best here for you guys
so i hope you enjoyed this
and uh and uh have a great week our
weekend it's friday right so that's
exciting
friday friday all right guys take care
we'll see you on
monday we've got a new episode coming
out on monday
and i'm telling you guys we've got some
really
great stuff coming out we're going up to
four episodes a week
coming soon officially it's happening
and the new one
is the shirt it's a surprise though
nobody tried to guess what it is
nobody tried to guess right dan right
i like that
five i don't know if we'll ever make it
to five a week to be honest four a week
is kind of
gonna max me out i think ethan you're a
hero
dude no one knows each other but you
make a community hole
wow oh he's weeping thank you
i feel like i was off my game today i
was just so
we did we just gotta get you things i
didn't even get time to like put the
proper preparation into this which like
i wish i would have i was just
i gotta figure out what's going on with
you i'm calling in
nutritionist yeah you gave me a list of
nutritionists
yesterday's pick from did you guys know
that that is like a
female dominated yeah like i looked
seriously there's so many and i only
found
one male and everyone else was female
yeah just kind of interesting yeah it
was weird but they're all like kind of
give me like
holistic medicine vibes yeah that's the
thing
i i knew you wouldn't like that so yeah
it's kind of trying to find something
like what you need
is sage oil i was like all right lady
i don't need sage oil tumeric i need a
[ __ ] gastric
bypass no jesus jesus
i need something more powerful than sage
oil [ __ ]
hey real quick before we go i just um
see the last few messages uh you guys
are amazing i'd love to call in
uh i have an awful first date story
where i projectile vomited all over his
house
[Music]
we'll do
and then for anyone who's wondering
where to send us clips to watch
where do you want them to send that
there should be a suggestion thread and
the discord
they're right there but if they are
right fine but if they're not on discord
if they're not on discord you can uh
probably the best way is to email us at
podcast
h3h3productions.com uh also
um i don't check it constantly but
um uh you can dm me on uh instagram
uh i check it probably once or twice a
week so if you send if you see something
on there and you want to send it um
you can send it to myself or or zach we
we take a look at that um but then yeah
again the discord if you can get on
there uh that's
probably the best way we hang out in
there all the time so
the discard is popping y'all yeah i'm
seeing the posts in there
pretty frequently and we've we've gotten
some good stuff in the past so uh so
jump on it well i hope you guys were
entertained i feel like i was off my
game
this episode sucked i'm so sorry
why is this great what'd you say there
is no discord link the way that you be
joined the discord here i'll just go
ahead and explain it what'd you say
i said everyone in the chat saying you
did amazing we love you
yeah this is a great episode i think
you're just too hard on yourself
right thank you right listen to a b yeah
abs my
my he's my uh what can i say he's my
onboard simp i thought zach was your son
hmm zach is my golden boy you're gonna
call it a b
or golden boy and my heart just no why
would i i never say that oh my god
there's only one goal
okay so just real quick since we're at
the end once again
if you want to join the discord link
your youtube account
to discord in the connections tab and
settings oh my god
there we go why did you do that
are we done no he's explaining this
why'd you make my hair loud oh what
uh connections tab discord
link your youtube once that's done you
will see
a join button to get into the server you
can't do it
on the mobile app the mobile app sucks i
don't have an explanation
[ __ ] with discord [ __ ] you dan [ __ ] you
dan do it from a browser
on your phone or just do it on a desktop
pc that's the way to do it
biden said this is [ __ ] epic you guys
want to browse reddit together
it's kind of fun biden said q and on is
bizarre and embarrassing and supporters
should seek mental health treatment that
is [ __ ] an
epic take by president phil isn't it i
mean that's kind of the only
way to respond uh you don't like it
you know i'm not the biggest biden fan
but that is the correct take on q and on
i mean
that's pretty great what do you think
about this
jennifer anderson 51 jack black at 51.
i gotta say jack black even though he's
overweight is in pretty good shape
i mean or i mean he looks yeah no like
he's physically in
capable yeah look at it look at the
grace
he just shaved his head too yeah he
looks so crazy
but you got to see this hello before we
go shaved
mother of love shaved
head jack black he shaved this whole
dome um
what is this does someone just rip his v
oh [ __ ] facebook
the lad bible you know what uh
i can't even i can't in good conscience
watch this even though it's what i'm
looking for
[ __ ] you you stole the clip from his
youtube video
and posted it on your [ __ ] [ __ ]
facebook page
and by the way they're getting paid for
this too people complain about youtube
youtube is by far and away the only
functional video platform facebook
enables content theft insane [ __ ] people
literally kill people on facebook live
and it's monetized these [ __ ]
are making money off stealing jack
black's video but
to be fair i do think these guys do ask
for permission
i don't think they got jack black's
permission i think they did
on the meat show what
oh this is kazak what else is up what do
you think
jeff black youtube i'm watching this
video meets now smoking these meats here
here i just want to show you the shave
jack black and we'll wrap it up okay
do you ever get the feeling you're not
going to be necessary for much longer
yeah what the [ __ ] is going on where is
it i should have just here it is okay
can i use this thing i love it took your
legend it just felt like
there's still a lot of a lot of
straggler hairs
and i need to go in for a closer show
four million that's the great thing
about shaving cream is it helps to raise
the hairs
i know my hair was glorious and long but
it was also getting in the way it was in
my eyes it was in my mouth
to top it all off some people say that a
beard is a covet catcher
yeah i don't know what the hell i'm
doing oh god this is going to take
forever
dude you can't shave your head like this
ask my lady if she can shave the back of
my head
just shave those legs just think of my
head as a weird
round leg
i think you got it i think we're done
god i have so much respect for barbers
what's jaybilin's jables follow me
he's awesome you know what's so sweet
about jack black in this channel he's
just doing this to
have fun with his kids [ __ ] awesome
he's such a legend
love that man
here's what i like to call the stealth
bomber
all right that's enough of that eh uh
guys thanks for watching i hope you all
had fun and have a fantastic weekend
and we'll see you on monday with a brand
new episode of the h3 podcast
all right take care everyone wish happy
birthday
happy birthday shredder oh crank it up i
want to learn the lyrics to this song
the whole damn crew goose and gaps with
all the guests you'll see the best
podcasts in the world take it from me jc
jay-z podcast
now
[Music]
you're watching h233
[Music]
and e.t sharing life with the ring jesse
outlook jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always doing bryce from the ashes
like